ja und hier hat im Bundestag die
Bundestagsvizepräsident schon gerade die
Aktuelle Stunde aufgerufen und der erste
Redner dachten wir kommt gleich zum Kult
aber jetzt gibt es noch
Klärungsbedarf aber das gibt mir die
Gelegenheit noch einmal zu erläutern
warum hier die unionsfraktionen diese
aktuelle Stunde ein gefordert hat denn
bisher hat er Kanzler Scholz in dem
Untersuchungsausschuss der Hamburgischen
Bürgerschaft angegeben dass er sich
nicht an den Inhalt der Gespräche mit
Christian olearius der Warburg Bank
erinnern kann die 2016 und 2017
stattgefunden haben allerdings wird nun
in dem Buch die Akte Scholz der Kanzler
das Geld und die macht laut eines
Protokolls des Finanzausschusses des
Bundestages vom März 2020
berichtet dass er durchaus etwas zum
Inhalt sagen konnte nämlich dass es
nicht mehr zu sagen gäbe als das was
schon bekannt sei und dass das
Steuergeheimnis ihnen hindere über
weitere Einzelheiten Auskunft zu geben
und deswegen sieht hier die aktuelle
Stunde doch noch offene Fragen die
unionspartei Fraktion sieht hier noch
offene Fragen und für die Unionsfraktion
spricht jetzt Volker Ulrich
sie werden dran gewesen aber jetzt ist
der Kollege dran
wollen sie noch mal tauschen ich meine
wir können hier alles machen Herr
mittelbergkamp sind sie außer Atem also
noch heute Erklärung hier sollte
eigentlich der erste Redner ein anderer
sein als Volker Ulrich Matthias
Mittelberg nämlich der war aber gerade
nicht da deswegen hat man getauscht und
jetzt wieder zurückgestellt also jetzt
Matthias Mittelberg für die
Unionsfraktion Kolleginnen bitte meine
Unachtsamkeit zu entschuldigen
in diesen Tagen in dieser Woche ist ein
Buch veröffentlicht worden von zwei
investigativjournalisten Oliver schröhm
und Oliver Hollenstein das heißt die
Akte Scholz der Kanzler das Geld und die
Macht so haben wir diese aktuelle Stunde
benannt aber das ist nicht der
eigentliche Anlass das ist vielleicht
der letzte Anlass um dieses Thema hier
in diesem Hohen Hause zu diskutieren man
könnte auch sagen gibt es nicht andere
Themen aber ich glaube es hängt schon
sehr auch mit den aktuellen Anspannungen
zusammen dass die Frage
an den wichtigsten Vertreter dieser
Regierung gestellt und seine
Glaubwürdigkeit und seine Integrität
betreffend dass diese Frage hier
diskutiert werden muss und in dieses
Haus gehört und der weiterreichende
Anlass
der weiterreichende Anlass ist dann eben
das Auftreten unseres heutigen
Bundeskanzlers und früheren Hamburger
Bürgermeisters Olaf Scholz vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg sein
Schweigen seine faktische
Aussageverweigerung dort in der bis
heute nicht geklärten Steuersache
Warburg
der Auftritt der ich sage das so
deutlich wandelnden Erinnerungslücke
Olaf Scholz ist wirklich bemerkenswert
er will sich an nichts erinnern keine
Details im Zusammenhang mit der
Steuersache Warburg gleichzeitig will er
sich aber sehr präzise daran erinnern
dass er in dieser Sache keinerlei
politischen Einfluss genommen hat ein
Widerspruch in sich
und dabei sind die Indizien und das sage
ich sehr deutlich dabei sind die
Indizien die mittlerweile schon auf dem
Tisch liegen und durch dieses neue
vorgelegte Buch erhärtet werden
bemerkenswert Hamburg war damals das
einzige der 16 Bundesländer dass die
cum-ex-rückforderungen nicht gestellt
hat dass die Gelder nicht zurück wollte
alle anderen 15 Bundesländer haben die
Gelder zurückgefordert Hamburg unter
Olaf Scholz hat es nicht getan da stellt
die Frage nach seiner politischen
Verantwortung
wir haben in den letzten Monaten auch
erfahren dass im Hause des damaligen
dann Finanzministers Olaf Scholz
Unterlagen zusammengetragen werden
sollten für den Untersuchungsausschuss
in Hamburg und dabei engste
Mitarbeiterinnen
E-Mails schrieben mit dem Inhalt mit
Olaf Seider noch zu diskutieren wie wir
die Termine mit Kaspar welschick und
centure einsortieren es ging also
offensichtlich darum dass Beweismittel
für einen Untersuchungsausschuss
einsortiert werden sollten ein höchst
bemerkenswerter und im Zweifel auch
unzulässiger Vorgang
Kontakte zwischen Herrn Scholz und Herrn
Carsten aufzuklären wir haben erfahren
dass eine Steuer Beamtin die zuständige
in Hamburg in intern also ehrlichen
Nachrichten von einem teuflischen Plan
gesprochen hat der dort umgesetzt worden
sei indem man auf die Rückforderung der
Millionen verzichtete das alleine ist
für sich schon ein bemerkenswerter und
höchst aufklärungsbe Politiker Vorgang
und zum Schluss und ich will das noch
mal ganz plastisch erklären herr Scholz
verweist ja immer darauf ihr könnt mir
das bis ins letzte noch nicht nachweisen
aber de facto sind schon die äußeren
Umstände aussagekräftig genug er sagt
ich wollte mich nicht einmischen
dann führt man vielleicht mit den
Beteiligten einmal ein Gespräch und
erklärt ihnen ich will ich kann ich darf
mich nicht einmischen alles in Ordnung
was aber stattgefunden hat war dass er
sich dreimal mit den Chefs der
warburgbank in seinem Amtszimmer in
seinem Büro getroffen hat um ihn ich
weiß nicht wie begriffsstutz ich diese
Banker waren um ihm drei Mal jeweils
eine Stunde lang zu erklären dass er
sich nicht einmischen will und dem
Chefdenker olearius hat Olaf Scholz dann
noch von sich aus hinterher telefoniert
um ihm wahrscheinlich noch mal zu
versichern möglicherweise hatten die
Banker ist immer noch nicht verstanden
nach diesen Gesprächen dass er sich
nicht einmischen will dann hat er den
einen noch mal angerufen um ihm noch mal
zu versichern ich will mich nicht
einmischen und zur Erhärtung seiner
Absicht hat er dann noch die Empfehlung
ausgesprochen ich kenne noch jemanden
anderen der sich auch nicht einmischen
will nämlich den Herrn schenscher der
ist hier Finanzsenator und weil ich so
genau weiß und wirklich so genau weiß
dass der sich auch nicht einmischen will
gebe ich euch den Tipp schickt mal eure
Unterlagen an den Herrn schenscher dann
könnt ihr sicher sein dass es keinerlei
Einmischung gibt wir wissen wie genau
nach diesen Gesprächen der Sachverhalt
ausgegangen ist dass nämlich die
Hamburger Behörde die eigentlich die
Gelder zurückfordern wollte dann
plötzlich gesagt hat wir machen das doch
nicht also hier spricht jetzt alles
dafür und das ist unser Anliegen dass
wir diesen Vorgang ganz intensiv weiter
aufklären müssen herzlichen Dank
viel Applaus von der Unionsfraktion hier
für Matthias im Mittelberg der hier die
aktuelle Stunde eröffnet hat Michael
schrodi kann nun die Position der
Sozialdemokraten hier erläutern
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren gestern hat
die Ampelkoalition in einer aktuellen
Stunde darüber gesprochen wie wir die
Gaspreis
Bremse jetzt implementieren wie wir
Menschen in dieser Situation schützen
heute hat die cdu/csu eine Aktuelle
Stunde aufgesetzt in der sie mit einem
Buch beschäftigt in dem alte
Unterstellungen neu aufgewärmt werden
deutlich ist nicht zu zeigen welche
Prioritäten die einzelnen Funktionen
setzen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
drei Anmerkungen zum Sachverhalt cum-ex
war immer kriminell zweimal betrug um
ex-geschäfte waren auch immer
illegal es gab auch keine Gesetzeslücke
Olaf Scholz war zu der Zeit der
cum-ex-betrügereien weder Hamburger
Bürgermeister noch war er
Bundesfinanzminister als
Bundesfinanzminister
hat er
Gesetze zur Einziehung von cum-exgeldern
und zur präventiven Bekämpfung von
cum-ex-betrügereien auf den Weg gebracht
wir wollten auch eine nationale
Anzeigepflicht für
steuergestaltungsmodelle auf den Weg
bringen um genau solche trügereien auch
aufzudecken dass er damals die cdu/csu
verhindert wir werden das
ampelkonditionen jetzt machen mal
schauen wie sie es dann zustimmen werden
oder ablehnen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren zweitens
es gab keine politische
Einflussnahme auf ein Steuerverfahren in
Hamburg vor der Hamburg-Wahl 2020 wurden
diese Unterstellungen platziert als Olaf
Scholz Kanzlerkandidat wurde erneut
jetzt auch wieder stets mussten
Medienvertreter wie auch die Politik am
Schluss einräumen da ist nichts es ist
nun seit zwei Jahren ein
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg
eingerichtet die Akten wurde hin und her
gewälzt und es wurden Zeugen vernommen
vielleicht fragen sie ja Mittelberg auch
mal ihre Hamburger Kollegen die Auskunft
ist doch ganz einfach kein einziger
Hinweis oder Beleg für eine politische
Einflussnahme steht in den Akten und
wurde jemals von einem Zeugen oder
erzeugen dort eben zu Papier gegeben ich
wiederhole beziehungsweise ich erinnere
der Spiegel sechste Achter 2021
Finanzbeamtin entlastet Olaf Scholz
4.3.2022 NTV staatsan Wald schützt
finanzamtsentscheidung zu warburg-band
und ich zitiere nochmal er sei mit der
Entscheidung damals absolut davor
gewesen sagte der Kölner
Oberstaatsanwalt Alexander Fuchs
deutlicher ist gar nicht das bestätigt
ist es gab eben keine Einflussnahme so
eine fachliche Entscheidung der
Finanzbehörde Hamburg in engen Austausch
mit der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln nehmen
Sie das zur Kenntnis meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
drittens der letzte verbliebene
Strohhalm für alle die Olaf Scholz etwas
anhängen wollen ist nun ein Protokoll
das Finanzausschusses vom Juli 2020 in
dem vermeintlich es Widersprüche gibt zu
den Aussagen mit den Treffen mit der
vakuumpbank wegen des hohen Guts des
Steuergeheimnisses ist sowohl die
Sitzung wie auch das Protokoll von der
damaligen Ausschussvorsitzenden als
geheim eingestuft worden Passagen sind
dort geschwärzt um eins klarzumachen die
SPD will die entstufung die Freigabe sie
will die entschwertung dieses
Protokolls wir wollen Transparenz
Offenheit und Klarheit meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren der zuständige
Ausschussvorsitzende der jetzt dafür
verantwortlich ist zu Endstufen und zu
entschmerzen wurde am 1 September
beauftragt vom Ausschuss bis Ende
September einen Vorschlag für die
endstufung vorzulegen das ist bis heute
nicht erfolgt meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
und am 1.10 stand im Spiegel
die Warburg Bank will nun auch
den Bundestag vom Steuergeheimnis
entbinden was dazu führen würde dass wir
entwärzten und Endstufen können wir
haben als Ampelkoalition noch einmal den
Ausschussvorsitzenden angeschrieben und
gesagt ist nun was gemacht worden damit
wir weiterkommen bei der Entwertung in
endstufung nein das ist nicht passiert
es wurde kein Kontakt bisher aufgenommen
übrigens der Ausschussvorsitzende gehört
der
cdu/csu-fraktion an meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir gehen davon aus
dass der Ausschussvorsitzende zeitnah
ein endschwertes und endstuftes
Protokoll vorbereitet dann müssen wir in
zukünftigen aktuellen Stunden der
cdu/csu und nicht mehr mit
Unterstellungen und Nebelkerzen
beschäftigen sowie den sorgen Anlegen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
so
ich komme jetzt erstmal zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 17a die Zeit für die
namentliche Abstimmung ist jetzt schon
drei Minuten vorbei draußen höre ich
gibt es auch keine Menschen mehr die die
Abstimmung an der Abstimmung teilnehmen
wollen deswegen frage ich im Saal hier
scheint das anders zu sein
da gibt es noch Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die gerne an der namentlichen Abstimmung
teilnehmen möchten
der nächste Redner hat noch nicht
abgestimmt okay dann verlängere ich die
Abstimmung bis die Möglichkeit für den
nächsten Redner gegeben ist auch noch
abgestimmt zu haben da geht es um den
Antrag der Linksfraktion zum Thema
Stromsperren bei Zahlungsunfähigkeit die
möchte die Fraktion verhindern aber
recht Glaser spricht jetzt erstmal für
die afd-fraktion bevor er dann abstimmt
der Herr Bundeskanzler spricht von
haltlosen Schauermärchen im Kern geht es
bei dem cum-ex-skandal um den
wahrscheinlich größten Steuerbetrug in
der Geschichte
dabei ist mindestens ein zwei ein hoher
zweistelliger Milliardenbetrag in
Deutschland hinterzogen worden auch die
Commerzbank die WestLB die HSH Nordbank
die Deutsche Post die KfW
Volkswagen und andere Unternehmen mit
öffentlicher Beteiligung stehen im
Verdacht sich daran beteiligt zu haben
die Staatsanwaltschaft in Köln ermittelt
mit 19 Staatsanwalt Teams gegen rund
1000 Verdächtige der Schwerpunkt der
betrügerischen Manipulationen fand in
den Jahren 2009 bis 2011 statt es geht
um Manipulationen bei sogenannten
cum-ex-geschäften was ist das
bei Dividendenzahlungen wird automatisch
die Kapitalertragssteuer einbehalten
bestimmte Empfänger von Dividenden sind
von dieser Steuer freigestellt und
können sich deshalb den steuerbetracht
vom Finanzamt zurückholen diese
Möglichkeit der Steuererstattung wird
mit hoher Raffinesse missbraucht und
damit der Fiskus betrogen das Bankhaus
Warburg in Hamburg war zwischen 2007 und
11 auf diesem Geschäftsfeld sehr aktiv
es hat sich 169 Millionen erschlichen
wie ein Wirtschaftsprüfer formuliert
davon sei ein großer Teil der
Forderungen inzwischen verjährt im Jahr
2016 droht ein weiterer Betrag von 47
Millionen zu verjähren
die mysteriösen Umstände dabei haben mit
der Person des damaligen Ersten
Bürgermeisters nach meinem
Bundesfinanzminister und heutigem
Kanzler zu tun
urplötzlich beginnt eine Betriebsprüfung
des zuständigen Finanzamtes die
Rückforderung zu überdenken schreibt der
Buchautor Hund der sich jahrelang mit
der Causa Scholz beschäftigt Sie
kontaktiert den Anteilseigner der Bank
olearius und dieser bezieht allen
alfonsik führen zweiten Bürgermeister
wegen seiner Kontakte zu Scholz ein
beides Mitglieder der feinen
Gesellschafter Hansestadt parallel
hierzu wie der bundeshaushaltspolitiker
Kars als Lobbyist in Berlin mandatiert
das ist der mit den roten Wollsocken der
im Deutschen Bundestag unablässig die
AFD mit Invektiven attackierte man
könnte auch sagen um im Milieu zu
bleiben mit Schmutz und Schund bewahrt
in dessen Schließfach fanden sie später
200.000 Euro von bis heute ungeklärter
Herkunft da wir fest an die
Unabhängigkeit der Hamburger Justiz
glauben wird der Vorgang sicherzüglich
aufgeklärt es wurde in dieser Zeit auch
eine Parteispende an die SPD von der
Bank von eben dieser Betroffenen Bank in
Höhe von
45.000 Euro getätigt in 2017 wurde einem
leidenden Beamten des
Bundesfinanzministeriums die noch nicht
verehrte Steuerforderungen gegen die
warburgbank die Höhe von 47 Millionen
bekannt
deshalb intensiv insistierte dieser
Mitarbeiter darauf dass die Hamburger
Behörde die Verjährung verhindern müssen
mit einem förmlichen Erlass ein relativ
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang erkennen Sie
hierüber ergaben sich durch Ermittlungen
der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln in Hamburg
wurde überhaupt nicht in der
mittelstrafrechtlich dort tauchten in
Köln Tagebücher von olearius auf in
denen von Treffen mit Scholz und den
Aktivitäten von Cars und pawelt schick
die Rede ist
zwei Gespräche von Scholz mit olearius
erfolgten ohne Zeugen und ohne
Niederschlag in den Akten in den
Büroräumen des Ersten Bürgermeisters
dies war deshalb prickelnd weil der
Finanzminister zuvor jegliche
persönliche Treffen mit olearius
bestritten hat ich selbst war Zeuge
eines solchen dementes in
Finanzausschuss
der tüchtige Beamte der Schaden vom Land
abwenden wollte wurde nach der
Amtsübernahme von Scholz in Berlin
überraschend frühpostioniert und die
Steuerforderungen in Höhe von 47
Millionen viel in die Verjährung
das ist also kein haltloses
Schauermärchen sondern beschreibt meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die Lage
der Nation
genauso verhält es sich mit der inneren
Sicherheit mit dem Schutz vor
Massenzuwanderung der daraus
resultierten Lager Wohnungsmarkt den
Staatsfinanzen den Bildungssystem der
Energieversorgung der beute-system im
öffentlichen Dienst entgegen dem
Leistungsprinzip nach Artikel 33
insbesondere auch in der Justiz und mit
der notleidenden Meinungsfreiheit
die Anerkennung für diesen Staat und die
Demokratie insgesamt meine Damen und
Herren schwindet messbar seit Jahren
dazu gibt es unendlich viele
Meinungsumfragen nicht weil die Bürger
schlechte Demokraten sind soll weil die
politische Aufgabe weil die politische
Klasse ihre Aufgabe nicht erfüllt
dieser Staat wird nicht von Bösewichten
delegitimiert mein letzter Satz wie die
Innenminister
sich selbst durch Organversagen und dem
bewusst herbeigeführten der bewusst
herbeigeführten Verzicht auf die
kulturelle Identität in diesem Land
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Glaser sie
haben jetzt noch Gelegenheit ihre Stimme
weil der Name abzugeben
[Applaus]
da sieht der letzte Sinn sozusagen dann
lassen wir das momentan noch zu aber ich
würde Sie bitten dass dort ein bisschen
zu beschleunigen denn wir müssen
geschlossen werden die Zeit können wir
überbrücken durch einen Antrag der
afd-fraktion Herr Kollege Brandner hat
einen Wunsch
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
ich habe keinen direkten Wunsch ich habe
einen Antrag zu Geschäftsordnung und
zwar nach reparagraph 42 der
Geschäftsordnung wir haben einen richtig
wichtigen Antrag hier zu behandeln oder
eine Aktuelle Stunde durchzuführen auf
Antrag der Fraktion der CDU CSU die
ersten drei Redner haben gesprochen wir
haben den Eindruck als wenn die einiges
aufzuarbeiten ist was möglicherweise
auch dazu führen kann das Bundeskanzler
Scholz wieder Erinnerungslücken
aufführen kann deshalb beantrage ich für
die afd-fraktion die Herbeirufung des
Bundeskanzlers zu dieser Debatte
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Brandner
die afd-fraktion verlangt den
Bundeskanzler zu zitieren dafür brauchen
wir die Mehrheit der anwesenden
Mitglieder des Hauses ich Frage wer den
Antrag der AFD unterstützt
die afd-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das sind
die Grünen FDP in SPD und Linke wer
enthält sich die Unionsfraktion damit
ist der Antrag Herr Kollege Brandner
abgelehnt ja das
nennt man Demokratie als nächster Redner
als nächste Arena das Wort der Kollege
Sascha Müller Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
Sascha Müller ist ob man im
Finanzausschuss für die Grünen
Herr Kollege Müller ein ganz kleinen
Moment ich kann jetzt ja Glaser hat
seiner Stimme abgegeben dann schließe
ich die Abstimmung und Frage noch einmal
ist ein Mitglied des Hauses Anwesen dass
seine Stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat
das ist erkennbar nicht der Fall dann
schließe ich die Abstimmung und bitte
die Schriftführer und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
so nun haben sie endlich das Wort der
Kollege Müller
Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
er gehört sicher zu den größten Fällen
an steuerskandalen in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der
steuerraub der mit den Schlagworten
cum-ex und kumkum bekannt wurde
vermutlich geht es allein im Fall cumex
um über 10 Milliarden Euro der
Gesamtschaden für die öffentliche Hand
kann bis heute nur geschätzt werden es
handelt sich also direkt um einen Griff
in die kasset der steuerzahler:innen und
damit dieser Fall auch am Ende
aufgeklärt werden konnte dafür haben
eine Reihe von Menschen Mut und
Hartnäckigkeit bewiesen und all ihnen
gilt unser besonderer Dank und ich
möchte in meiner Rede die Zeit nutzen
einigen zu danken da wären zuallererst
die wissen-blauer die trotz des Risikos
beruflicher Nachteile die Behörden und
die Öffentlichkeit mit Informationen
versorgt haben und die erst so vieles in
Gang gesetzt haben was vermutlich
ansonsten unter der Decke geblieben wäre
sie konnten zeigen wie umfassend das
Problem steuerraub ist und welche Lücken
gestoppt werden müssen und genau deshalb
arbeitet diese Koalition auch an Gesetz
zum besseren Schutz von wissen-blauern
es wurde Zeit
da es wären weiterhin dir es waren
weiterhin die betriebsprüferinnen und
Prüfer in der Finanzverwaltung die bei
diesen
kapitalertragssteuergetriebenen
Geschäften dran geblieben sind sich in
die komplizierte Materie reingefuchst
haben und am Ende nach jahrelanger
Kleinstarbeit genug Material
zusammengestellt haben um die
Anschuldigungen gerichtsfest machen zu
können in einigen Fällen benötigte es
benötigte es sag und schreibe sieben
Jahre Betriebsprüfung bis ein
Strafverfahren eröffnet werden und so
der Plünderung der Staatskasse Einheit
geboten werden konnte danke dass Sie
daran geblieben sind
ein großer Dank gilt auch den
Parlamentariern die sich hier in diesem
Haus in einem Untersuchungsausschuss
intensiv um die Aufklärung der Vorgänge
gekümmert haben für uns Grüne möchte ich
besonders meinen ehemaligen Köln oder
unser ehemaligen Kollegen Dr Gerhard
Schick nennen der heute an anderer
Stelle weiter wichtiger Arbeit für ein
transparentes Finanzsystem und so großen
Einsatz gegen Steuerbetrug leistet und
danke auch an den Untersuchungsausschuss
in der Hamburger Bürgerschaft der sich
ohne Rücksicht auf Personen ebenfalls
intensiv um Aufklärung bemüht ein großes
Dankeschön gilt auch an Korrektiv eV und
ja natürlich
natürlich auch an Oliver schröhm und es
ist für mich und ich war selbst war sehr
lange journalistisch tätig schwer
erträglich das gegen Herrn schröm für
seine damaligen Recherche dass dareus
größtes vorgegangen wurde eine weitere
juristische Strafverfolgung ist man muss
ja fast sagen glücklicherweise im
sandverlaufen als Jahre später
Ermittlungen gegen die Redakteuren und
Redakteure der finanziell times
aufgenommen wurden dem Fall Wirecard
umgereimtheiten aufdecken es ist klar zu
sagen eine aufmerksame mit unter
unbequeme und kritische
Berichterstattung ist für ein Netz
funktionierende Demokratie so wichtig
auch bei der mühsamen Aufarbeitung von
cum-ex und auch wenn es zuweilen wie in
einem gerade zitierten neu erschienenen
Buch Bilder von uns Politikerinnen und
Politikern gezeichnet werden die wir
nicht teilen müssen aber die wir
aushalten müssen und ich bin mir sicher
die Beteiligten bzw der Beteiligte wird
das aushalten und wir als Ampelkoalition
haben ein gemeinsames Interesse die
Öffentlichkeit hat ein Recht auf
Aufklärung aller noch offenen Fragen und
unterstützen das und Kollege Schröder
hat schon darauf hingewiesen gerade
treiben wir gemeinsam auch wir als
ampelfraktion im Finanzausschuss
gemeinsam voran dass ein Protokoll aus
der zum Ende der letzten
Legislaturperiode aus dem
Finanzausschuss
entstuft wird und wir wollen das und wir
wirken auch gemeinsam darauf hin es geht
geht auch unter anderem um die
warburgbank ich möchte einmal kurz in
Erinnerung rufen die
warburg-stils in Eigenhandel sie ließ
sich so steuern erstatten schließlich
erklärte der Bundesgerichtshof im Juli
letzten Jahres dass die warburgbank dem
Bund 176 Millionen Euro für
cum-ex-geschäfte zurückzahlen muss meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein solcher Fall darf sich in
Deutschland nie wieder ereignen
cum-ex-geschäft ist in den Deutschland
strafbar steuerraubt kann gestoppt
werden und er wird gestoppt werden es
geht schließlich um das Geld der
Menschen hier es geht um unser
Gemeinwohl wir brauchen dazu Schutz für
wisse blauer bestmöglich ausgestattete
Finanzverwaltung und Ermittlungsbehörden
und natürlich auch gute Gesetze damit
die Behörden ihre Arbeit nachgehen
können es geht um das Vertrauen in
unseren Rechtsstaat lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam daran arbeiten ich danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
Sascha Müller war das für die Grünen es
ist natürlich schwierig da an dieser
Transparenz zu arbeiten wenn es so Größe
große Erinnerungslücken gibt auch das
wurde hier schon viel kritisiert dass
dieser Fall nicht gerade von besonders
viel Transparenz Zeug Christian Görke
spricht jetzt für die Linksfraktion der
finanzpolitische Sprecher die investige
tiefer Recherche der Journalisten
Strömen und Hollenstein die heute
Gegenstand der Aktuellen Stunde ist
belegt 1 es gab und es gibt Filz
zwischen industriellen zwischen Bankiers
und der Politik in der Freien und in der
Freien Hansestadt Hamburg zur Wahrheit
gehört auch am Mittelberg das kann ich
nicht ersparen dass sie als CDU in der
Zeit von Ole von wolf-spendenzahlungen
aus der Warburg Bank erhalten haben dass
nur mal zur Vollständigkeit aber ich
komme jetzt mal zu den
Sozialdemokraten die auf dem Höhepunkt
der Steueraffäre aus dem weit geweigten
Konzernbereich von Christian eularius
und Max Warburg mal mehrere 10.000 Euro
auf die Kasse überwiesen bekommen haben
ich will an dieser Stelle gar nicht auf
die von der Staatsanwaltschaft im
Bankschließfach von Johannes Kaas
gefunden
240.000 Euro Bargeld eingehen
Zusammenhänge Fragezeichen ist das
Zufall wir werden sehen was das für
undurchsichtige ex-geschäfte sind hat
mein damaliger Kollege Fabio De Masi
hier ganz zutreffend im Parlament mal
auf den Punkt gebracht ich gehe in den
Supermarkt gebe eine Bierflasche ab
nehme ein Pfandbon legen dann auf den
Kopierer und lasse dann mit meinen
Freunden diesen ganz häufig mir an der
Kasse ausbezahlen mit dem Unterschied da
ist die Supermarktkasse das Finanzamt
ist und das bei cum-ex es nicht um den
Flaschenpfand geht sondern um Milliarden
im Ergebnis
der größte Steuerbetrug in der
Nachkriegsgeschichte mit diesen dubiosen
Finanzgeschäften haben Banken große
Investoren in deutsche Staat und sage
und schreibe
35,9 Milliarden Euro Bedrohungen mit
diesem Geld meine Damen und Herren
könnte man zum Beispiel in diesem Winter
jeden privaten Haushalt die Gasrechnung
übernehmen meine Damen und Herren im
Fall der Privatbank Warburg geht es aber
um mehrere hundert Millionen Euro die
Staatsanwaltschaft Köln beschuldigt
Herrn olarius der Steuerhinterziehung
mittlerweile sind die Urteile über
ehemalige Mitarbeiter der Bank gefällt
die müssen hinter Gittern und die in
warburgbank musste 176 Millionen an die
Staatskasse zurückführen auch die 47
Millionen Euro auf die merkwürdigerweise
die Hansestadt Hamburg kurioserweise
verzichten wollte und heute aus meiner
Sicht nach wie vor ein Schatten auf den
damaligen Ersten Bürgermeister und heute
im Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz werfen
deshalb erwartet nicht nur das Parlament
und meine Fraktion sondern auch die
daraus da draußen dass hier endlich
Tacheles geredet wird und vor allem
reiner Tisch gemacht wird um Fragen zu
Folge
wollen fast 80 Prozent der Menschen da
draußen dass sich der Bundeskanzler
ausführlich zu diesen
70 Prozent kaufen ihm auch seine
Erinnerungslücken nicht ab und ich
glaube und ich glaube im übrigen er hat
sich auch wirklich im Widersprüche
verheddert und die neueste Buch
veröffentlicht die Akte Scholz gibt
einiges davon zum besten eine dieser
Widersprüche ist meine Damen und Herren
das im Herbst 2020 eher in diesem Hause
sagte sie er könne sich nicht vorstellen
wie zu irgendeiner Zeit irgendjemand der
diese Geschäfte verstanden und mit ihnen
zu tun gehabt habe tatsächlich annehmen
konnte dass er etwas legales tut und
dennoch traf er sich
dreimal mit Christian solarius
wohlgemerkt zu einem Zeitpunkt als
bereits er beschuldigt da in einem
Ermittlungsverfahren war und die Razzia
in der warburgbank stattgefunden hat ein
anderer Widerspruch ist aus Olaf Scholz
als Erster Bürgermeister den Herr lagius
empfohlen hat das verteidigungsschreiben
der warburgbank obwohl sie es schon in
der Steuerverwaltung lag von oben über
den Finanzen in norddeutsch chenscher
politisch einzuspen was dann auch noch
mit einer Abzeichnung passiert das
Ergebnis ist bekannt und das ist dass
das keine Sonderbehandlung ist meine
Damen und Herren
das können die Menschen draußen
sicherlich ganz schnell verstehen und
ich sage Ihnen auch als ehemalige
Finanzminister kann ich so etwas auch
nicht verstehen und meine Damen und
Herren der SPD
sorgen Sie dafür dass ich ihr
Bundeskanzler erinnert und dass er sich
ehrlich macht und vor allen Dingen dass
er sich der Befragung im Finanzausschuss
endlich stellt es wäre nach der
Veröffentlichung des Buches die Akte
Scholz glaube ich ganz gut beraten
vielen Dank
der ehemalige Finanzminister
Brandenburgs war das
die Aktuelle Stunde um sie und der
Tagesordnungspunkt 17a über das Ergebnis
der namentlichen Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Klimaschutz und Energie zu dem Antrag
der Abgeordneten Amira Mohammed Ali dr
Gesine Lötzsch Gökay Akbulut weitere
abmonate und der Fraktion DIE LINKE
Strom und gastsparen verbieten
Drucksachen
202686 und 20 38 53 zu unterrichten
abgegebene Stimmkarten 643 mit ja haben
gestimmt 603 mit Nein haben gestimmt 37
Enthaltungen 3 damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen wir
kehren nun zurück zur aktuellen Stunde
und das Wort hat der Kollege Markus
Herbrand FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident ich habe
mich als erstes gefragt welche Rechte
denn die Union an dem Buch hat also man
kann ja im Grunde genommen eine bessere
pr-veranstaltung zwei Tage nach
Erscheinen dieses Buches gar nicht haben
ich danke aber den unionskollegen und
Kolleginnen sehr für die Gelegenheit
dieses skandalakte cumex und kumkum
heute noch mal aufzurollen dabei ist die
Fixierung auf den Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz als oppositionsreflex der Union
natürlich sehr nachvollziehbar
allerdings sollten wir auch nicht darauf
reinfallen wir müssen durchaus auch
weitere Hintergründe und
Verantwortlichkeiten dieses Skandals
benennen dabei wird klar dass die Union
besser nicht nur mit dem Finger auf
andere zeigen sollte manchmal ist auch
der Blick in den Spiegel durchaus
angebracht
worüber wir reden ist jetzt vielfach
ausgeführt worden noch unter dem
ehemaligen bundesfinanzminister Wolfgang
Schäuble ereignete sich der größte
steuerbetrugskandal in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Gauner haben sich viele Milliarden Euro
durch sogenannte
cum-ex-betrügereien vom Fiskus also von
uns allen erschlichen
erschreckenderweise war das BMF unter
seinem damaligen Minister erst in den
Jahren 2012 und 2016 nach jahrelanger
Untätigkeit zu dem Entschluss gekommen
den Betrug ein Ende zu setzen so wurden
2012 cum-ex-geschäfte verboten und noch
einmal vier Jahre später folgten dann
kumkum alleine durch diese Verzögerung
sind Schätzungen zur Folge nochmals
mehrere Milliarden Euro für den
deutschen Fiskus verloren gegangen
alle Beteiligten und die und der
politisch Verantwortliche Finanzminister
wussten also spätestens seit 20 20 11
das Betrüger rein im Milliardenbereich
laufen und dennoch vergehen bis zu fünf
Jahren bis der Geschäftemacherei ein
Riegel vorgeschoben wird seit vielen
Jahren beschäftigen wir uns nun im
Parlament mit der Aufarbeitung der
damaligen fehlerketten in den
Regierungsjahren der großen Koalition
war an dieser Stelle leider wenig
Enthusiasmus zu erkennen die in die
Opposition gewechselte Union scheint
aber endlich bereit zu sein auch die
eigene unrühmliche Verantwortung für den
jahrhundertbetrug an den
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern
aufzuarbeiten
selbstverständlich gehört dabei auch die
Frage nach Verantwortlichen auf allen
Ebenen auf den Tisch das Parteibuch darf
dabei einer lückenlosen Aufklärung nicht
im Wege stehen nur durch vollständige
Transparenz bei allen Beteiligten kann
verloren gegangenes Vertrauen wieder
zurückgewonnen werden auch Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz muss diesem Anspruch gerecht
werden und darüber aufklären was er wann
wusste und was er genau wann getan hat
dasselbe gilt aber selbstverständlich
auch für den ehemaligen Finanzminister
Wolfgang Schäuble und die jeweils
verantwortlichen Fachminister auf
Landesebene ich freue mich sehr über den
offenkundigen Willen der Union
auch diese für Sie sicherlich eher
unbequem Fragen endlich anzugehen
dasselbe gilt aber auch für den
Bundeskanzler mit seinen bisherigen
Ausführungen zu diesem Themenkomplex hat
er aus meiner Perspektive
nachvollziehbar dargestellt wie er sich
in seiner Zeit als Erster Bürgermeister
von Hamburg Verhalten hat sollte es
darüber hinaus allerdings Aspekte geben
die zur Aufklärung beitragen müssen
diese natürlich ebenfalls offengelegt
werden auch Olaf Scholz selbst sollte
ein großes Interesse daran haben den
Diskussionen und Verdächtigungen und mit
maximaler Transparenz entgegenzutreten
die FDP-Fraktion wird dabei niemanden
vorverurteilen allerdings bekommt von
uns auch niemand einen Freifahrtschein
wir arbeiten daher sowohl im
Finanzausschuss als auch in Abstimmung
mit dem Bundesfinanzministerium an der
Offenlegung aller Details zum
cum-ex-skandal die Akte Warburg ist
dabei ein wichtiger ein wichtiges
Puzzleteil welches auch durch
möglicherweise weitere Beiträge von Olaf
Scholz an die richtige Stelle gerückt
werden sollte herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Herbrand
und der nächste Redner ist Volker Ulrich
erst der rechtspolitische Sprecher der
CSU-Landesgruppe und natürlich dadurch
auch Mitglied in der Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wir
leben in
herausfordernden Zeiten für
demokratische Institutionen und die
Stärkung der Glaubwürdigkeit in diese
und ihre zentralen Repräsentanten ist
eine der wichtigsten Fragen dass der
cum-ex und kumkum Skandal insgesamt
weiter aufgearbeitet werden muss ist
selbstverständlich es geht aber um
spezielle Fragen im Warburg Scholz
Skandal und diese dürfen wir nicht
einfach wegdiskutieren die Hamburger
Finanzbehörde hat die März 2016 vor
Ablauf der Verjährungsfrist die
Möglichkeit nicht genutzt zu Unrecht
erstattete Kapitalertragsteuer in Höhe
von 47 Millionen Euro von der Warburg
Bank zurückzufordern im Jahr 2017 wurden
weitere 43 Millionen Euro erst nach
zweimaliger WE durch das
Bundesfinanzministerium von Seiten der
Hamburger Verwaltung
zurückgefordert die Übernahme von
politischer Verantwortung für diesen
Komplex ist bis heute ungeklärt und das
fordern wir ein
der heutige Bundeskanzler hat sich im
Zeitraum von September 16 bis November
17 insgesamt drei Mal mit dem Chef der
Hamburger Warburg Bank getroffen und ihm
sogar telefonisch geraten eine
Stellungnahme aus Sicht der Privatbank
an den damaligen Finanzsenator
Tschentscher zu schicken die
Öffentlichkeit hat von diesen Treffen
aufgrund der Auswertung sichergestellt
hat Tagebücher des Beschuldigten
bankmanagers erfahren dass der heutige
Bundeskanzler selbst die Anzahl der
treffen nämlich drei nicht von sich auf
sondern nur auf Vorhalt und schrittweise
einräumte ist wenig transparent und
enttäuschend
wer ein Amt an der Spitze einer
Regierung hat der muss sich die freie
gefallen lassen und sie beantworten
weswegen er mehrmals den Chef einer Bank
trifft gegen den bereits zu diesem
Zeitpunkt wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird und
weshalb eine Rückforderung der
Finanzbehörde im Raum steht politisch
klug war das nicht der Bundeskanzler hat
ausgeführt dass er keine konkreten
Erinnerungen an diese Treffen haben das
müssen wir zur Kenntnis nehmen der Punkt
ist aber auch dass sie gesagt hat er
habe auf jeden Fall
politisch keine Einflussnahme
herbeigeführt die Frage ist also
erinnert sich nicht an die treffen aber
daran dass keine Einflussnahme
stattgefunden hat beides passt nicht
zusammen hier muss Aufklärung erfolgen
wir haben ein Staats politisches
Interesse daran dass in Krisenzeiten
unser Land durch sachlich richtige und
moralisch gefestigte politische Führung
regiert wird
ein zumindest in groben Zügen
vorhandenes Erinnerungsvermögen an
Termine und Sachverhalte aus jungen
Vergangenheit ist eine Eigenschaft die
man von einem Bundeskanzler verlangen
muss
es darf nicht das Bild bleiben der
Bundeskanzler habe an nicht unerhebliche
Sachverhalte keine Erinnerung im
Interesse seiner eigenen Glaubwürdigkeit
sollte der Bundeskanzler diesem Eindruck
nachdrücklich
entgegenwirken die bitte geht also heute
von diesem Haus an die Bundeskanzler
geben Sie der Transparenz und der
Aufklärung im Sinne der Glaubwürdigkeit
den Vorzug gegenüber Erinnerungslücken
und vergessen
dass diese Aufklärung Not tut und dass
die Einforderung von Transparenz zentral
ist muss auch im Interesse der
regierenden Koalition sein schließlich
heißt es auf Seite 9 des
Koalitionsvertrags und ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis das Präsidenten wir wollen
doch mehr Transparenz unsere Demokratie
stärken uns leiten die Prinzipien
offenen Regierungshandelns Transparenz
Partizipation und Zusammenarbeit dieser
Anspruch an Transparenz muss in der
Sache Warburg und im Komplex nicht
zurückgeforderte Steuerschuld eindeutig
eingelöst werden das ist eine Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit unserer Demokratie
insgesamt die aktikum Ex darf nicht
geschlossen werden bis nicht auch dieser
Warburg komplett aufgeklärt ist und da
bitte ich und die Mitwirkung aller die
daran beteiligt sind herzlichen Dank
die Aufforderung von Volker Ulrich war
das hier noch einmal
diesen Skandal aufzuklären bisher ist es
doch sehr unbefriedigend was man offen
offiziell darüber weiß Tim Kissen
klyssendorf jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
die Aktuelle Stunde ist ja ein
parlamentarisches Mittel was wirklich
wichtig ist wir haben hier Gelegenheit
außerhalb von Gesetzesvorhaben und
Anträgen über Themen zu diskutieren die
wirklich von relevant sind die aktuell
von Bedeutung sind für die Menschen in
unserem Land und die möglicherweise auch
von unseren Debatten dann profitieren
können indem wir die Meinungsaustausch
auch noch mal darlegen als wir davon
erfahren haben dass sie eine Aktuelle
Stunde einberufen wollen habe ich mir
überlegt okay was könnten Themen sein
die hohen Preise vielleicht die
Energiekrise möglicherweise die
Situation im Iran die Situation in der
Ukraine die Raketenangriffe vielleicht
alles nicht die aktuelle Stunde die sie
einberufen haben geht um ein Buch ein
Buch das keinerlei Neuigkeiten bringt
über die Erkenntnisse die bereits
vorliegen keinerlei neuen Informationen
das eigentlich nur das zusammenträgt was
bereits bekannt ist und jetzt muss ich
mal ganz ehrlich über ihre
Oppositionsarbeit sprechen Friedrich
Merz und deswegen habe ich mir das Zitat
auch noch mal ausgedruckt um das auch
korrekt zu zitieren hat am 1 März ich
weiß ja sie mögen das nicht wenn man
Herrn Merz an seine März reden erinnert
hat am 1 März gesagt konstruktive
Opposition heißt die Regierung zu
kritisieren wo es nötig ist ihr
Alternativen gegenüberzustellen wo es
möglich ist ihr aber in schwierigen
Lagen auch zu helfen das Land zu
regieren das ist dann unser gemeinsamer
Erfolg da hat er recht sie haben ganz
recht Herr Künstler da hat er recht nur
gehen wir mal das Zitat durch
konstruktive Opposition heißt es die
Regierung zu kritisieren wo es nötig ist
sie kritisieren nicht die Regierung sie
kritisieren auch nicht das
Regierungshandeln hier sie kritisieren
überhaupt nichts an hindertlicher
Politik die gerade läuft sie kritisieren
etwas was in einer Finanzbehörde in
Hamburg alles was durch mehrere
Ausschüsse einem Untersuchungsausschuss
in Hamburg untersucht worden ist ein
Finanzausschuss der Deutschen
Bundestages und sie beschäftigen sich
überhaupt nicht mit der Politik und den
Herausforderungen in diesem Land
kommen wir zum zweiten Punkt ihr
Alternativen gegenüberzustellen wo es
möglich ist wo stellen sie
Regierungspolitik hier Alternativen
gegenüber Ihre aktuelle Stunde
beschäftigt sich ja auch nicht damit wie
man aus cumex lernen kann das was zum
Beispiel der Kollege Herbrand oder der
Kollege Müller oder der Kollege schrody
dargelegt hat wie wir mit cumex anders
umgehen können welche inhaltlichen
Schlussfolgerungen daraus gezogen sind
sieht fokussieren sich allein darauf
Erinnerungslücken hier und klare
Aussagen da sie beschäftigen sich
überhaupt nicht mit den Inhalten das
Schlimme an dem commex-skandal sind doch
die entgangenen Steuergelder und nicht
das Verhalten in irgendwelchen
Ausschüssen sondern was wir daraus
lernen und wie wir nach vorne blicken
können
und jetzt komme ich zum letzten Punkt in
dem Zitat ihres Oppositionsführers ihr
aber in schwierigen Lagen auch zu helfen
das Land zu regieren wenn man ganz
ehrlich ist die ganzen letzten Wochen
und Monate konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit wurde eingestellt das
einzige was sie tun und das hat die
niedersachsenwahl auch schon gezeigt ist
die Ampel anzuschießen und die Regierung
zu destabilisieren und das tun sie mit
einem Kalkül dass das wohl dieses Landes
in den Hintergrund geraten lässt und das
allein parteipolitisch dominiert ist das
ist nicht nur das ist einfach komplett
am Thema vorbei es ist überhaupt nicht
der Verantwortung gerecht die die als
größere Oppositionspartei haben sie
degradieren sich mit dieser aktuellen
Stunde zu einer personifizierten
Verkaufsförderungsmaßnahme für ein Buch
und nichts anderes sonst es geht nur um
Inhalte es gibt Null um das Land
das ist dann unser gemeinsamer Volk ist
der letzte Satz und es ist neben nicht
unser gemeinsamer Erfolg sie haben sich
schon lange von der konstruktiven
Oppositionsarbeit verabschiedet es kommt
keine Vorschläge es kommen solche
aktuellen Stunden in der letzten Woche
war schon die Aktuelle Stunde Klarheit
und Führung es gibt keine inhaltlichen
Themen sie versuchen hier den
Bundeskanzler bei zu zitieren wahlweise
an Harbeck herbei zu zitieren obwohl er
gleichzeitig im Haushaltsausschuss auf
ihre eigenen Fragen antwortet es ist
Woche für Woche das gleiche ich bitte
Sie wirklich bringen Sie eigene
Vorschläge lassen sie uns inhaltlich an
den Sorgen und Nöten der Menschen
diskutieren lassen sie uns gemeinsame
Arbeit für dieses Land machen und dann
geht's auch gemeinsam voran so ist es
kein gemeinsamer Volk so ist es nur ein
Erfolg der ampelregierung wie dieses
Land regiert wird und nichts anderes
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege küssendorf
nächste Redner ist der Kollege Dr
Sebastian Schäfer Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
organisierter Steuerbetrug in
Milliardenhöhe ist ein Verbrechen ein an
unserer Gesellschaft ein Verbrechen an
unserem Staat
dem kann nur mit voller Transparenz und
lückenloser Aufklärung begegnet werden
da geht es um sachorientierte
sale und mühevolle Arbeit und
selbstverständlich darf es dabei keine
Schonung geben das haben die
bundestagsuntersuchungsausschüsse zu
cum-ex und zu Wirecard gezeigt dazu
gehört aber auch dass im Rahmen der
schärfsten Schwerter die wir als
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
haben weder mit Vorverurteilungen noch
mit vorweggenommen freisprechen
gearbeitet wird
ich frag mich was genau der aktuelle
Anlass der Debatte heute ist eine
parlamentarische Buchbesprechung als
Freund der deutschen Gegenwart Literatur
hätte ich da noch noch viele Ideen ich
empfehle zum Beispiel ganz besonders
identity von methus Sunshine aber ich
fürchte für parlamentarische
Buchbesprechungen sind wir nicht gewählt
wenn wirklich neue Informationen
auftauchen dann gehören die
selbstverständlich aufgeklärt und
aufgearbeitet dass allseits als gut
recherchiert beschriebene und viel
gelobte Buch die Akte Scholz ich habe es
noch nicht komplett lesen können bringt
nach meinem Kenntnisstand jedoch keine
wirklich neuen Erkenntnisse das macht es
nicht weniger interessant denn es stellt
zusammenhängend da und hilft beim
Verständnis und ich möchte hier
unterstreichen wie wichtig die Arbeit
der
investigativen JournalistInnen wie
Oliver schröm und Oliver auch
Hollenstein ist wie viele Finanzskandale
wären ohne JournalistInnen in den
letzten Jahren deutlich unter der
wahrnehmungschwelle geblieben oder wären
irgendwann still und heimlich unter den
Teppich gekehrt worden Panama leaks
Wirecard oder P&R die Liste ist leider
sehr lang
die Aufdeckung bei vielen der Skandalen
ist letztlich übrigens nur ins Rollen
gekommen weil es Whistleblower innen mit
gewissen gab die großes Risiko
eingegangen sind warum erwähne ich das
die große Koalition hat die Einführung
eines effektiven whistleblowerschutzes
in Deutschland verhindert und die Ampel
hat ein hinweisgeberschutzgesetz
ordentlich ins Deutsche übersetzt auf
den Weg gebracht dass bald den
parlamentarischen Prozess durchlaufen
haben wird
wurde umfassend in einem
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
behandelt auf Initiative von Bündnis 90
die Grünen wir wollten und wollen volle
Transparenz und Aufklärung aber im
Rahmen von
parlamentarischen Prozessen und nicht
den schaufensterdebatten eben weil es um
die Aufklärung des größten deutschen
steuerraubs geht wir wollten
herausfinden wo staatliche Strukturen
versagt haben um sie für die Zukunft zu
verbessern ich will insbesondere an die
großen Verdienste von Gerhard schicker
erinnern der mit der finanzwende das
Thema jetzt mit Mitteln der
Zivilgesellschaft weiterhin intensiv
bearbeitet
leider wurden damals die
untersuchungsausschussunterlagen einfach
abgeheftet das ist zu wirklichen
Reformen bei der Aufsicht und den
staatlichen Strukturen kam dafür hat es
dann noch den wirecard-skandal gebraucht
laut Schätzungen des Steuerexperten
Christoph spengel von der Uni Mannheim
ist uns allen seit der Jahrtausendwende
durch cum-ex-geschäfte ein Schaden von
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro entstanden
und leider ist es die absolute
Untergrenze der Schadensumme davon kommt
bisher nur ein Bruchteil von etwa 1,4
Milliarden Euro gesichert werden das
Kapitel cum-ex ist auch juristisch
keineswegs abgeschlossen die
Staatsanwaltschaft Köln und das
Landgericht Bonn werden diese
Steuerhinterziehungen noch Jahre
beschäftigen aktuell sind erst einige
wenige der Betrüger verurteilt worden
die Ampel wird weiter an Maßnahmen gegen
missbräuchliche Steuergestaltungen
arbeiten und auch den Daten und
Informationsaustausch zwischen
Finanzaufsicht und Steuerbehörden bei
Verdachtsfällen ermöglichen dabei geht
es nicht nur um den Reputationsschaden
für unseren Rechtsstaat für unser Land
sondern auch um Steuereinnahmen um
Steuersubstrat dass wir zur Bekämpfung
der multiplen Krisen dringend benötigen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Schäfer
[Applaus]
nun lauschen wir den Ausführungen des
Kollegen Matthias Hauber
cdu/csu-fraktion
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Deutschland steht vor
riesigen Herausforderungen allein schon
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
die unsichere Versorgung mit Energie der
explodierenden Preise Deutschland
bräuchte jetzt ein Bundeskanzler der
ehrlich führt und dem die Menschen
vertrauen können doch Deutschland hat
Olaf Scholz
der Steuerskandal cum-ex steht für
Milliarden Euro um den kriminelle
unseren Staat und damit uns alle in
Deutschland betrogen haben und dieser
Skandal zerstört jeden Tag mehr die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers das
Buch die Akte Scholz der Kanzler das
Geld und die Macht enthüllt neue
Erkenntnisse es unterlegt bekannte
Vorwürfe mit weiteren Fakten und es
wirft weitere Fragen an den
Bundeskanzler auf während 15
Bundesländer gegen diesen steuerraub zu
Felde gezogen sind
und auch versucht haben das geraubte
Steuergerät zurückzuholen hatten die
cumexkriminellen in Hamburg
Narrenfreiheit unter dem ersten
bürgermeister Olaf Scholz ob in Hamburg
oder im Bund ich erwarte von einem
Regierungschef dass er sich nicht mit
steuerkriminellen trifft dass er ihnen
keine Tipps gibt und dass er Ihnen
stattdessen klipp und klar sagt ihr
kommt mit eurem steuerraub nicht
ungeschoren davon aber das Gegenteil hat
Olaf Scholz getan und nicht nur
und nicht nur bei Comex ist die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers auf
einem Tiefpunkt zwei aktuelle Beispiele
erstens in der Generaldebatte sagte der
Bundeskanzler kürzlich er würde alle
Probleme schon lösen bevor andere sie
überhaupt nur erkennen wie kann man nur
so anmaßend seiner Bundeskanzler
zweitens Putin nutzt Energielieferungen
als Waffe dazu äußerte sich der
Bundeskanzler vorgestern er sagte
wortwörtlich Zitat ich war mir immer
sicher dass er das tun würde Olaf Scholz
will also die gaserpressung durch
Russland vorausgesehen haben wieso hat
er da nicht gegengesteuert Olaf Scholz
war jahrelang Arbeitsminister
Finanzminister Vizekanzler und sogar als
Scholz schon Kanzler war als russische
Truppen schon an der ukrainischen
Ostgrenze aufmarschiert waren da
verteidigte er immer noch Nord Stream 2
wer will den Bundeskanzler eigentlich
sowas abstruses glauben und nur beim
Hamburger Steuerskandal
da will Scholz sich an nichts mehr
erinnern und dabei werden immer mehr
offene Fragen aufgedeckt warum hat Olaf
Scholz mehrfach die Steuerbetrüger in
seine Amtsstube empfangen sie angerufen
ihn sogar Tipps gegeben anstatt das
Steuergeld einfach zurückzuholen wieso
musste das Bundesfinanzministerium mit
zwei Weisungen das von Scholz geführte
Bundesland zwingen die Steuermillionen
zurückzuholen gab es wie die
Staatsanwaltschaft erwägt eine Zitat
koordinierte Löschung von E-Mails und
sollten Zitat
Führungspersonen bewusst von
Verantwortung ferngehalten werden indem
diese nicht per E-Mail kontaktiert
werden
und was ist eigentlich aus dem
Versprechen des
spd-chefhaushälters Johannes Kaas an die
Banker geworden dass man den warburgfall
wieder aufrufen werde wenn die SPD das
Bundesfinanzministerium übernehmen werde
kurz danach übernahm Scholz das
Ministerium und dann musste genau der
Abteilungsleiter gehen der durch die
Weisungen die Steuer Millionen vor der
Verjährung gerettet hat er wurde mit 59
Jahren unter Scholz in den vorläufigen
Ruhestand versetzt
und bis Juli 2020 da konnte sich der
Bundeskanzler an zumindest eintreffen
erinnern da hat er sogar dreimal drüber
gesprochen erst kurz danach als
investigative Journalisten weitere
Treffen aufgedeckt haben beginnen seine
Erinnerungslücken wieso kann sich Scholz
seitdem auch an das erste Treffen
eigentlich nicht mehr erinnern hat Olaf
Scholz die Unwahrheit gesagt immerhin
hat sogar seine Familienministerin einst
wortwörtlich mehrfach gesagt Zitat stolz
er den Bundestag belogen Zitat einer
grünen wieso hat Olaf Scholz den
warburg-bänkern den Tipp gegeben ihr
Schreiben an den Finanzsenator zum zu
senden obwohl ihm das Schreiben längst
vorlag jedenfalls wollte direkt danach
die Hamburger Behörde die steuermillion
plötzlich dann doch verjähren lassen
Zufall wohl kaum und wieso steht Olaf
Scholz eigentlich auf der dankesliste
die der warburg-chef handschriftlich
angefertigt hat vier von zehn Namen sind
auf der Liste sogar abgehakt der
Steuerberater sowie drei SPD-Politiker
Johannes Karst über den haben wir schon
eine Menge gehört gerade Alfons
pawelschik spd-prominenz aus Hamburg mit
üppigen Lobbyismus Honoraren von Warburg
und als dritter Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz alle diese Fragen sind offen
dennoch schweigt Olaf Scholz auch heute
die Ampelkoalition hat mit der
Regierungsübernahme das
aufklärungsinteresse verloren das haben
wir heute auch gemerkt aber wir werden
die Akte Scholz nicht schließen Herr
Bundeskanzler
endlich für Klarheit zu sorgen vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Hauer und damit
kommen wir zum nächsten Reden an der
vorletzte Redner in dieser aktuellen
Stunde
hat auch nicht geholfen als nächster
Redner kommt zu uns der Kollege Frank
Müller Rosentritt FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr Gerda Präsident sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Journalist
Sebastian Hult hat vorgestern auf n-tv
ein Online-Beitrag veröffentlicht mit
dem Titel ist Scholz ein Lügner als
hätte sich daran mit dem neuen Buch die
Akte Scholz der Kanzler das Geld und die
Macht auseinander und bereits in der
unter Überschrift heißt es einen
schlagenden Beweis für Scholz
Verstrickungen in die cum-ex-affäre
bleiben die Autoren schuldig
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
auch wenn das Erscheinen eines Buches
hier ein eher nachrangiger Anlass für
eine aktive Stunde ist steht es Ihnen
selbstverständlich nur pluralen und
lebendigen Demokratie als
oppositionsreflex zu zum Verfahren es
ist allerdings schon äußerst verwegen
dass das über Jahre von ihrer Partei
geführte Bundesland oder Wolfgang
Schäuble jahrelang diesem illegalen
Treiben oder darum gesehen hat
und am Ende stellen Sie sich hier im
Bundestag hin und mach den ehemaligen
Ersten Bürgermeister Scholz zu zeigen
aber sie wissen doch jetzt am besten
wenn sie mit einigen Finger auf Urlaub
Scholz zeigen zeigen Sie mit drei Finger
auf sich zurück deshalb unglaublich und
von 2009 bis 2017 war Wolfgang Schäuble
den ich übrigens als in der letzten
Wahlperiode als Bundestagspräsident sehr
schätze Finanzminister von 2011 an
wusste man für diesen unfassbaren
Gebaren und erst kurz vor dem Ende
seiner Zeit also Finanzminister wurde
letztendlich all diese Geschäftsgebaren
verboten da kann ich nur sagen Wolfgang
Schäuble komm temporär
Liberalen stehen für das Rechtsprinzip
und auch die Steuergerechtigkeit ein
dazu zählt für uns dass wir Straftaten
auch konsequent verfolgen möchten und
ich möchte an dieser Stelle meine
geschätzten Kollegen Florian Tonga
zitieren mit Erlaubnis des Präsidiums er
sagte am 9 September 2020 hier an dieser
Stelle in der Debatte cum-ex
steuerdealsterbank und Reuter Politik
als Vertreter der Oppositionsfraktion
FDP an die Adresse des damaligen
Bundesfinanzminister Scholz ich zitiere
ich unterstelle dass das was wir
inzwischen von ihnen erfahren haben
vollständig ist und dass das wir und das
wir nicht auf weitere Dinge stoßen die
den bekannt waren die aber bisher nicht
genannt worden sind das ist glaube ich
auch eine Frage des Respekts wo
parlamentarischen Institutionen Zitat
Ende einer Aufarbeitung dieser
cum-ex-geschäfte oder Warburg Bank der
Beteiligung oder eben nicht Beteiligung
des damaligen Hamburger Bürgermeister
Scholz fand statt findet statt und wird
auch so lange stattfinden wie sich
Anschuldigen und Beweise ergeben sollten
aber die Unschuldsvermutung geht eben
auch für einen ehemaligen Ersten
Bürgermeister Hamburg aber legen Sie
dies bitte eben nicht als in dubio pro
reo aus denn auch wenn viele Zweifel an
der Sache hegen es gibt eben aktuell
kein Angeklagten Olaf Scholz eine
Strafanzeige gegen Olaf Scholz schaltet
den 22 tanzen nach der
Staatsanwaltschaft sieht auch die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Hamburg keinen
anfassverdacht auf mögliche Beihilfe zur
Steuerhinterziehung und
wer steht auch völlig zu Unrecht unter
Generalverdacht und darauf möchte ich
auch eingehen das ist dann auch durch
diese eine Verfehlung einer Bank die
Bankenbranche an sich getreu dem Motto
alle Banken betrügen dabei sind das doch
die Banken die zentraler Bestandteil der
Wirtschaft sind welche das Geld für die
Finanzierung zur Verfügung stellen über
90 Prozent aller Investitionen in
Deutschland werden von privaten
Investoren Unternehmen getätigt und mit
Hilfe unserer Banken finanziert und
deshalb sollte man in diesen Zeiten
alles dafür tun um diesen Motor im Laufe
zu halten und Banken gerade in ohnehin
rezessiven Zeiten nicht mit zusätzlichen
Kapitalanforderungen belasten
bedrohenden enormen Zusatzbelastung
durch den antizyklischen und sektoralen
Kapitalpuffer welche zu Zeiten beste
Konjunktur ausgedacht wurden um eine
Überhitzung zu vermeiden legen die Axt
an zukünftige Finanzierungen welche aber
gerade bei der Transformation eine
nachhaltige Wirtschaft in die Schaffung
von Wohnraum sowie die Bildung von
Wohneigentum dringend benötigt werden
hunderte Milliarden Euro an Kapital
werden der Markt somit nicht zur
Verfügung stehen oder Kredite werden
durch den Regulator zusätzlich zu den
ohnehin schon gestiegenen Zinsen so
teuer dass das fast unmöglich wird die
verabredeten 400.000 Wohnungen die wir
bauen wollen zu bauen meine Damen und
Herren der Union das das was ich gerade
ausgeführt habe das wäre mal eine
Aktuelle Stunde Wert die die Wirtschaft
und das Land nach vorne bringen würde
anscheinend reden wir heute über ein
Buch wie klein kann man sich eigentlich
nur machen die Union wobei ich die
Fähigkeiten von Autoren Strömen und
Hollenstein in keinster Weise hier heute
in Abrede stellen möchte und entgegen
den grundzeiten im Finanzministerium
wird das BMF und noch besser Lindner und
sein Team um Katja Hessel und Florian
Tonka den Kampf gegen Finanzkriminalität
im Gegensatz zu ihm deutlich ausweiten
dazu bündeln wir Kompetenzen unter dem
Dach einer neuen Behörde außerdem
stärken wir die finnische Intelligence
Unit als zentrale Stelle für Geld welche
Verdachtsmeldungen unterrichten auch
eine neue Zentralstelle für Geldwäsche
Aufsicht die Aufsicht auch über den
nicht Finanzsektor koordiniert das BMF
will und dafür bin ich den
Finanzminister sehr dankbar
steuerferndes stärken und insbesondere
schwerere Fälle der Steuerhinterziehung
und aggressive Steuergestaltung
bekämpfen ein letzter Satz in eigener
tolle Sache könnten wir die Parade
überall die Finanzen selbst verwalten
und bewahren hätten wir nicht wie bei
ihnen cum-ex sondern das Prädikat
zumachen komm laute vielen Dank
nun denn ich habe mich damit gerechnet
Kollege Müller Rosentritt dass sie immer
gibt ja noch schneller reden kann als
ich und jetzt in einer mir völlig
unbekannten Sprache
bevor der Kollege Dr Jens Zimmermann das
Wort hat muss ich zurückkommen zu den
Wahlen
die Zeit für die Wahlen ist vorbei ist
noch ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend
dass seine Yahoo aber
sie dürfen jetzt auch gerne
also darf ich darf ich mal darauf
hinweisen das mache ich jetzt gerne dass
wir sehr viel Zeit hatten und
also ich finde die Unionsfraktion
wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend mit dem
was jetzt Geschäftsordnung nichts
passiert ich kann unterbrechen bis sie
jetzt gewählt haben aber ich kann auch
sagen wir lassen ja Zimmermann noch
hören und dann gehen sie zur Urne wie
wir es vorhin bei einem Glaser gemacht
haben
salomonisch in Abwandlung der zwingende
Vorschriften der Geschäftsordnung
entscheide ich das jetzt einfach mal so
als letzter Redner hat das Wort der
Kollege Dr Zimmermann SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident das ist
sehr großzügig wer auch schade gewesen
wenn der Hauer jetzt hätte dich zu hören
können danke für das Interesse meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Buch die Akte Scholz wurde
am 11.10 veröffentlicht darüber reden
wir an dieser aktuellen Stunde und die
Begründung die die Union mitliefert ist
durch das Buch bestimmten nun offene
Fragen und ich würde mal sagen das ist
eine reichlich steile These denn kaum
ein Thema und das haben wir in dieser
Debatte jetzt auch schon erlebt ist
eigentlich so umfangreich beleuchtet
worden wir haben mehrere
Untersuchungsausschüsse gehabt es gibt
unzählige Veröffentlichung gefühlt vom
Pförtner in der Hamburger Bürgerschaft
bis zum Finanzminister wurden dutzende
und aber dutzende Zeugen und Zeugen
Untersuchungsausschüssen gehört fast
zwei Jahre parlamentarischer
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg es hat
sich am Ende eine Sache gezeigt Olaf
Scholz hat keinen Einfluss auf das
Steuer Verfahren der Warburg Bank
genommen meine Damen und Herren
denn was ist eigentlich die Frage dieses
ganzen propans der hier aufgeführt wird
die Frage ist gab es im Jahr 2016 eine
politische Einflussnahme auf die
Entscheidung der Finanzbehörden in
Hamburg und war deren Entscheidung in
Sachen Warburg Bank damals richtig und
es ist ja wichtig dass man sich bei
dieser zentralen Frage ein Bisschen auch
mal auf all das stützt was die
Untersuchungsausschüsse was sie denn
alles so zu Tage geführt haben alle
Zeugen der Finanzbehörde haben ausgesagt
alle diejenigen die dieses
Steuerverfahren geführt haben haben
ausgesagt es gab keinerlei Beeinflussung
durch die Politik sie hätten sich
eigenständig und ausschließlich an
fachlichen Gesichtspunkten entschieden
in den Akten und das ist ja das Schöne
an Untersuchungsausschüssen da kann man
die ganzen Akten herbeiziehen in den
Akten finden sich ebenfalls keinerlei
Anhaltspunkte für diese These wenn sich
die Aussagen der Beamtinnen und Beamten
im Untersuchungsausschuss anschaut mit
den aktenvergleicht alles deckt sich
also demnach kann man feststellen die
Beamtinnen und Beamten hatten keinen
Zweifel damals das zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt wir reden über 20 16 das ist
sehr sehr wichtig das ist damals eben
rechtlich nicht sicher gewesen wäre
diese Rückforderung damals zu stellen
das ist das was die Akten und die
Ergebnisse der Untersuchungsausschüsse
zu Tage geführt haben meine Damen und
Herren
und diese Geschichte die sie hier immer
erzählen von wegen 15 von 16
Bundesländern wir müssen ja immer ein
bisschen zurückgehen in 2016 fakt ist
Hamburg hat 2020 das Geld
zurückgefordert und ich finde es gibt ja
es gibt ja einen es gibt ja aus meiner
Sicht einen absoluten Kronzeugen der
über jeden Zweifel erhaben ist und das
ist der Kölner
Oberstaatsanwalt Fuchs also der oberste
cum-ex-jäger des Landes von 20 16 und 17
der musste ja auch Aussagen vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss und solche sagen
was der gesagt hat zum Verhalten der
Hamburger Steuerbehörden er hat
wortwörtlich gesagt ich war mit dem
Verhalten vollkommen dakor also er war
vollkommen einverstanden mit dem Handeln
der Hamburger Steuerbehörde das sagt ein
Kölner
Oberstaatsanwaltschaft der oberste
cum-ex-jäger der ist nicht aus Hamburg
der hat nicht mal wie andere
Staatsanwältin sp die Parteibuch sondern
der hat gesagt das war richtig ich war
davor damit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und das interessante an der Sache ist
dieser Oberstaatsanwalt hat im
Untersuchungsausschuss ausgesagt dass
der Fall damals noch nicht ausreichend
ausermittelt gewesen ist und dass es ihm
eigentlich recht war dass die Hamburger
das nicht zurückgefordert haben er sah
er begründet es deswegen hätten die
damals mit einem halb garen Fall das
gemacht und sie hätten vor Gericht
verloren wäre die ganze
cum-ex-geschichte einfach so
weitergegangen das sagt ein ehemaliger
Oberstaatsanwalt in dieser Sache und ich
finde das muss man doch mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich fasse zusammen
es gibt trotz umfangreichster
Ermittlungen
keinerlei Beweise die Finanz die
Finanzverwaltung beteuert nicht
beeinflusst geworden zu sein der oberste
cum-ex-jäger der Jahre
2016/17 sagt die Haltung war vollkommen
richtig insofern kann ich mit einem Satz
aus diesem Buch Enden das nämlich der
letzte Satz in diesem Buch da war nichts
es hat keine Einflussnahme gegeben schon
Dank auch das war von Olaf Scholz
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Zimmermann
damit schließe ich die Aktuelle Stunde
und so das war jetzt etwas uneindeutig
da gab es noch viel Uneinigkeit ob eben
in diesem neuveröffentlichten Buch ist
und Neuigkeiten gibt zum cum-ex ist
Skandal und dadurch hat man hier nicht
so ganz auf der gleichen Basis
diskutiert